salvan rusia evoluciona en un hospital
de erie pensilvania ya no necesita
respirador y es capaz de hablar tras el
ataque del que fue objeto el viernes el
atacante sospechoso hoja de matar se
declaró inocente en la corte fue acusado
de intento de asesinato y agresión el
joven de 24 años es estadounidense de
padres libaneses en su perfil de
facebook que ya ha sido eliminado
mostraba su admiración por el ayatolá
jomeiní que emitió una fatua contra
salman rushdie fue detenido en la
conferencia de nueva york- llevando un
permiso de conducir falso a nombre de
uno de los fundadores de hezbollah
aparecido en 2008 su abogado se negó a
hacer comentarios
-ha de matar vivía en esta casa en el
estado vecino de nueva jersey fue
registrada por el fbi que incautó
material informático que nunca hubiera
pensado que alguien así vivieran en el
mismo barrio es increíble
cuando escuché la llegada a los
helicópteros no entendí es terrible lo
que ha pasado absolutamente aterrador
fáil en
el escritor es conocido mundialmente por
su libro los versos satánicos la venta
sigue prohibida en india y en varios
países musulmanes